tell us a bit about and being human and
you work on lands my work will be human
I did the pilot regional pilot got
picked up and I did three in a bit
series and my journey with George is
finished now but either an amazing time
and being in that show and being
welcomed by the sci-fi community has
been something incredible sci-fi
community as a restraint doesn't it but
you know the sci-fi fan base has just
been amazing the mazing thing really
amazing experience
is it something that you haven't
anticipated being so big that's been
huge hasn't it it's been great I loved
it so everything you do that you feel
passionate about you hope will do well
so it's an incredible feeling
exhilarating and also very satisfying
and makes you feel very comfortable with
the way things going because it's
security I suppose and the fact you're
in something that people love and they
want to watch that's the best thing ever
because there's no point in making a TV
show that people slag off or are not
fans of so have something that people
are really kind of devoted to is for an
actor a very unique thing and very nice
you also have been in Sherlock haven't
you and that's something else that
people are really devoted to again am i
amazing I mean to be to be in that show
is just you know I've done doctor being
human Sherlock it really feels like I'm
kind of stretching myself all over the
place trying to pop up in sci-fi high
but only an amazing thing and that's the
most nervous I've ever been about
something txon on TV i sat there when I
went to a party at friends the day
before and I really thought about it and
so many people comment to me going
biggest show on TV how you feeling
I thought you know what I'm feeling
quite nervous no I was fine before you
said there that's why sat down watching
it and my heart was racing and I was
checking Twitter I had to turn it off
I'd actually seen it before i sat and
had a little sneaky preview with in the
office with mark and sue virtue in that
market 80s and it's just as you go out I
just it's because everything I do is
very culture and digital and you know
it's it a lot of people see it but it's
you can kind of go under the radar to
some people but that's like primetime
BBC one bang you're out there like 12
million 30 million or something there's
not the same with dok2 and Christmastime
when I did have a karna Minogue that was
the same but I didn't have as big a part
in that and I felt more partly ensemble
but this felt like I don't know so it's
nerve-wracking but thankfully I think I
got away with it no one's discovered me
yet so you mentioned things like Twitter
and finding out what people were
thinking of stuff in the fan base is
that something that can be quite
daunting and is it something you try to
put out of your mind when you're doing
stuff I don't think you can putting out
your mind I can't anyway I'm massive
tweeter and by the tweet about what I'm
eating anything I just like a load of
old rubbish I think Twitter is so
important to the instant review of the
public of anything now like you you
don't have to wait for a professional
review everyone's been on view which is
dangerous in itself but it's kind of
there straight away it's like simple
things I was at Luton Airport a little
while ago and it was everyone was
evacuated and I didn't know what's going
on I'd checked on Twitter and a search
bar Luton Airport had come up and said
there has been fires gone off somewhere
in Leuven Airport everyone's been
evacuated
okay that's what it is and it's like
it's just instant and that's special and
unique and I think it serves sci-fi
people very well because sci-fi people
seem to enjoy a good forum and enjoy a
chat and the social side of it because a
lot of these conventions I go to it's
very social and lots of people friends
would connect from all over the country
come together meet and go to these
conventions and it's like having a pen
pal I suppose and I think Twitter serves
there in it selfies I'm terrified if
they do start slugging you off and
people don't like you you find that out
as well and it's narrow escaping it but
I'm a fan you mentioning about the the
Syfy community in particular and you've
done conventions and stuff before it's
it's something that you were listening
that you enjoyed as a as a youngster as
a teenager I love Star Wars and I loved
The Goonies and Ghostbusters and I used
to collect action figures now who's to
battle and staff and the Millennium
Falcon and
you know we'll so they're kind of be
allowed as an adult to still sort of
enjoy that and you're not gonna get
locked up and it's fine you can look at
toys and you can you know get involved
in that world is is brilliant it's it's
you're allowed to do it here and that's
what's great because I think outside in
someplace if you talk about it you might
get kind of stoned in the street but but
also I think I think that's kind of
current for now I think what's gone
before the fact that doctor who came
back resurfaced and became like a
phenomenon it suddenly became acceptable
to come out as a sci-fi fan well I think
before a lot of people kind of locked
themselves in their bedroom underneath
to do better at the comic with the torch
and kind of like and especially the
forums and Twitter and stuff that I was
saying I think now it's kind of quiet
you're allowed you know and you see a
lot of kind of couples here and their
partners into it and the other one isn't
into it but they embrace it in the go oh
yeah it's like it's okay it's not it's
not like terrible anymore they've got a
big cosplay contest going on saying it's
loads of guys and girls who addressed in
amazing costumes that have had a chance
to check it out yet but if you were to
take part in a cosplay contest
what would you come dressed as Shiro
probably no I wouldn't I would go as an
icon is something that's very skimpy I'd
want to show off my boss how arrogant no
I would yeah you get that in there no I
would they were like oh I quite like the
Ghostbuster outfit I think like a
chronic looks like quite sexy in a weird
way I quite like it with the gun and
it's like one piece isn't it yeah yeah
there's like Kwik Fit fitter but like
different colour with the badge that's
what I'd like if anyone wants to send me
a Ghostbusters outfit then feel free
finally what have you got coming up next
next thing I've got things coming out a
few films coming out this year I'll film
another film there's sci-fi based called
grabbers which is about these aliens
that descend on an irish village and the
only way to ward them off is if you've
got alcohol in your systems the whole
village has a lock-in so that's coming
out later in the year couple other films
I start
in him and her again which the BBC three
show do but a couple in a bedsit and
then I'm doing a comedy drama for ITV
called the job lot which is like setting
a Job Center which is very current for
now the current climate too serves that
and that's me for the rest of the year
it is a few other bits and bobs coming
out but can we expect from him and her
in the next season I'm ready I don't
know yet I've actually got two scripts
on home to read I've got around to yet
I think the same sort of you know we're
gonna move on and Laura's pregnant now
and you know where does that take her
and Paul and Steve and Becky's
relationship is obviously going to
deepen and what's going to happen then
and I think my t16 goal Chesky is just
such an incredible writer and everything
he does is just you know amazing
you